greenback is a new book from British
author Jason Goodwin tracing the history
of paper money in the US he spoke
recently in Washington DC for about 45
minutes coming out on this cold night
and it's the pretty much the first thing
about me is that I'm a Brit and you
might be thinking well why would this
guy be coming here to tell us about our
money and it's a bit like it's like
going to talks know the Eskimos or um
talk about arrogance to the French or
something like that
and in fact I think maybe it takes
sometimes it takes an outsider to see
what's under everyone's nose and if
you're you know using the money every
day its money and maybe it's you
it's what's in your stock market it's
what's in your pocket and if you come in
from the outside you see that there are
things to it which which maybe insiders
don't see so easily and I was very
interested struck that you know coming
from from old Europe as it's now known
that in that in Europe we have a lot of
we have a lot of history you know we
have a lot very old houses we have sort
of monuments and so which go back a long
way but we have a lot of very new
currencies and our money is new even
though some of our institutions are very
old I curiously coming to America of
course it's a place whether you know the
houses are quite new but the money is
very old and that the dollar really does
have a history that goes back a long way
and I finally you know looking at the
history of the greenback is a bit like
going into an old historic house and
then starting to you know peel
layers and look at look at different
aspects or different eras of history
that it represents I thought I'd just
practice to explain a little of my
there's an inspiration for this how I
got into it I'll just I just read you
just a moment from the introduction it's
both the introduction to the book and a
story my introduction to the to the
American dollar this is how I spend my
first dollar when I was 17 I took sick
on a bus going towards the railway at
our mother but the guide book called
Ahmedabad India's Birmingham I've been
travelling in India for a month on the
back of the bus it said horn please and
okay Tata the driver burnt jaws before a
postcard of Carly on the - I found a
commercial travelers hotel or nobody
spoke English and spent the night
sweating in a cold room in the morning I
gritted my teeth got dressed and tried
to find a way out of Ahmedabad the
railway terminus was Victorian Gothic
with pinnacles and Venetian windows it
was full of people in pajamas the line
stretched four yards and moved slowly
after a long wait I asked for a ticket
to Bombay the ticket clerk consulted a
piece of card and shook his head in two
days maybe the people behind me were
losing patience starting to thrust
themselves into the gap between me and
the grille their hands full of money I
felt too ill to give way I eased a green
banknote out of my money belt and put it
under a pile of dirty pink rubies I
slipped the pile across to the clerk
first-class sleeping berths to Bombay I
said the clerk no more examined the
dollar than I had
he made it disappear and gave me a small
cardboard ticket with a berth number
written on it soon afterwards I watched
her mother dad slide away through the
carriage window and the next day I
reached Bombay so that was how my dollar
bill went on a bride I was impressed by
the dollars power to bend the rules even
miles from its home
I haven't bribe anyone else since but
I've spent dollars and earned dollars a
decade ago in Eastern Europe I got to
enjoy the Cold War buzz of a dollar bill
I like the worst nickel and dimed
sometimes I take a dollar check into the
bank in England and paid in across the
counter and then I have a a meteor
Schmoe Mandir day trader or a Hollywood
consultant or an art expert or drugs
baron it's quite different from banking
a thousand quid or 1,500 euros or
240,000 lira handling dollars puts me
figuratively close to the money the
cashier always crosses out the printed
pound sign on the paying in slip and
puts in a dollar sign with two down
strokes just like a cartoonist
indicating a swag bag in English
cartoons boatless bags are marked swag
in American cartoons people even get
dollar signs in their eyes
this whole that I say goes back a long
way I mean it really takes us back to
you know to the 1500s and well away from
from this from this new world we go back
to Central Europe where the first
dollars were actually minted as coins in
the place called York in style which was
a bohemian Valley Tom means Valley in
German and it's the same as our English
words del or Dale and from Europe him to
Tolkien these coins which were fantastic
they were they were very large they're
very pure silver they weighed an ounce
they were very good for the Renaissance
of trade that was taking place in Europe
at the time and they spread all across
Europe and as soon as they reached
England they would no not as tall as but
as dollars and the again the Spanish
took them over to South America where
they were known as well as tons but as
Pacers and pieces of age so the dollars
are kind of pirate kind of currency
initially and then the dollar appears at
the birth of the nation and that's quite
again very interesting that there is a
relationship between obviously between
the money and the development of the
Republic and which is one you can see in
the in the strike and ography at the
dollar much what's on the dollar but
right off you know in 1775 the first act
of Congress the first thing they
actually do is to vote themselves some
money and they vote themselves not pants
shillings and pence which is what they
were actually using in the colonies at
the time but it's Spanish dollars which
they which was the sort of the surrogate
currency and they didn't actually have
any of these Spanish dollars which they
vote on themselves so they went up and
printed the English it was an expression
of confidence and faith in the nation's
future i won which didn't immediately
pay off because actually started with
two million of these dollars printed in
what was called the Continentals and
they ended up I think by the war's end
with about 240
of them and they were worth nothing
which is whether there's a phrase
something's not worth a continental
that's what it means
there are jolly times at the end of the
Revolution when people sailors coming
back into Boston were paid off with some
of these dollars they realized that they
were completely worthless so they
haven't sown into suits and they went
through the town and have paraded around
the town in these fantastic sort of
money seeds and there was a kind of sort
of hilarious sight I think to this
appalling sort appreciation of the
currency and inflation which made people
like Washington very hungry so then we
have the net there that the money is
there and it's the first it's the first
symbol of a united united America as the
Continental Army comes before the flag
certainly comes with force on Liberty
bells and President President
generations and speeches on the state of
a nation America has also invented paper
money earlier which is again you know
this this there's a link this link
between the history of America and the
history of its money and and and the
idea of paper money as a as a loan from
the future to the present I think is a
very perhaps a very American sort of
optimistic way of thinking so paper
money Harry was literally invented here
had been used in China but there's no
connection between China and obviously
in the its invention here and although
people keep talking about it in Europe
no one actually gone so far as to to
produce it and then I think that money
the dog does something interesting it as
paper money its value depended on trust
and I think that in a community which
was essentially a community of strangers
during the 19th century when immigration
sort of became for large and constant
and that the West Was the frontiers
being rolled out more and more the
American experience is one of arriving
in a in a place where everyone was a
stranger to you everyone else I think
Dickens was on a train he he said except
to the attendant I feel such a stranger
in your country said hey mister were all
strangers here and I think that that
money became in a sense that dollar was
one of those a unifying unifying forces
as an idea of it create an idea of
Americans of people who spend dollars
and in fact I was thinking of this as an
idea of this sort of connectivity in
this as a drugs to anti-drug campaign
going on right now which is saying you
know your money is your money did this
so that's the sort of that's the flip
side of it though yeah the good side is
we're all in this together and we know
people have faith in the currency and it
moves around the bad side is know we're
all in this together and you know you're
you're responsible for what goes on in
the cent and this is something about
that in the 1830s when when there's a
big battle between or particularly
President Jackson and the man who ran
the bank of the United States Nicholas
Biddle and they're very very different
figures and they were bound to class
well they Biddle voted for Jackson which
his deep regret I'm Jackson fingered the
money power he was he he was very
suspicious of all these these bankers
manipulating currency and he said I
ready to destroy the bank she did
perhaps it was because the bankers dealt
with money so easily every day they
failed to notice something that
Outsiders he visited the country
chorused one after another they all said
that America's most distinct nation
Allah Parekh turistic was an obsession
with money even a thoughtful enthusiast
like Alexis de Tocqueville founded at
the bottom of everything he decided that
money was inevitably the mayor
existence in a democracy Hamilton
Alexander Hamilton wasn't to the
Treasury secretary and apparently been
pushing at an open door when he tried to
make money the yardstick of Americans
ambition and the principle of social
order the dollar seemed to do the work
that class or creed did in Europe it was
America's Bishop its King its squire
from Michel Chevalier in 1839 called a
passion for money was not greedy passion
in the main it simply reflected the
importance of dollars and cents in a
society that had no other standard to
work to as time went on the we had this
that those all of the wild period the
great really out of the frontier the
banks that wild cats and so on
eventually after the Civil War money was
nationalized it was brought into
Washington you've got the bureau down
the road to print the staff the Treasury
issued the money and so on in order to
in fact initially just to win the war
against the south
but then it was realized you know the
government had taken control and this
idea that they had before as all state
banks kind of producing money privately
kind of faded away and and then again
you had the dollar went through another
sort of transformation because it became
it became a self expression of the
American Empire and I guess that's one
of the reasons I I was attracted to this
whole story was that in in a way it is
the story of another Empire like I kind
of think Empire stories and the story of
the make of the conquering as it were in
the West is certainly an imperial one
even then perhaps beyond was on their
doorstep so you get these great doors I
mean I as as a sort of you know I cover
this but they're these fantastic ones
with you know very improving sort of
more tales and messages you get
goddesses and some time that everyone
everything was goddess is everywhere a
lot of those lovely mata as you see in
Washington buildings and
you've got goddesses of electricity and
the goddess of steam and so on sort of
bringing the light of Washington to the
masses and and that's all progressive
anybody was all on the money you know
they they never missed a trick and they
would there's one I'm really when it has
had all these goddesses lots of them um
chariot and they're holding Thunderbolts
and um and some cherubs are coming down
and right at the side and they're
pouring out of the Dome of the Capitol I
don't quite sure who they are and
there's me but they're they're saying
you know we've come to bring you light
we got to dazzle you with these
Thunderbolts from Washington and I
suppose it was a sort of it was a it was
a moment when the country was settling
into this idea the frontier was closed
it was settling in the energies of the
country now become much more turned in
on themselves to also to progressive
improvement and some self-improvement
raising everybody up cetera and then
another change and the final change
which has been very interesting occurred
really in the in the 20s when they set
the dollar to look the dollar that we
have today and that's sort of weird
because in Europe you know currencies
come and go they change you know the
pound note we do have a patent loading
what's the point you know all the other
countries of Europe of most of them have
gone in for the Euro that sort of nimbly
named until feeble bland
currency where nothing is quite what it
seems to be and completely lacks the
that's sort of the eccentricity of the
American dollar which I find quite
endearing and we get this dollar which
is much more comes in the 20s is much
quieter doesn't really say anything to
anyone certainly not try trumpeting
anything and I think by the 20s when it
was invented you know America didn't
have to trumpet anything it was it had
made it you know and it was where
everyone was looking in the world weary
Europe and so on look to America for
guidance and Wilson went to Europe and
told them how to behave
to do any good that Second World War and
Americans of financial power was really
enshrined after that war and everybody
had to pick their currencies to the
dollar and in fact all that all the
countries of the world after the second
one we were keeping all that built in
New York which would have been written
in a really enough enmity than 50 years
before the Americans are sort of bad
risk in a way kind of exciting but I'm
safe and so I think we end up with this
dollar which which hasn't changed and I
think that has its meaning to I think
it's very important that it hasn't
changed I think the efforts to change it
be made and the Secret Service would
like to the guys at the bureau I think
would like to to see changes to it they
said you can make it easier so harder to
counterfeit because country has always
been a problem
they didn't reduce more colors and
things but I gather that it didn't float
at the White House this idea and that
you know it'd be like kind of messing
around with a flag no so the dollar I
think as it stands is here to stay and
in fact today I've been asked quite
often whether me what what's gonna
happen in the future or is it going to
fade away and if it was just gonna use
plastic as I've been thinking about that
and I think the answer is is no I don't
think it will because because in a funny
way money is a you know ugly as it is
and root of all evil and all that it's
also some form of communication I think
whatever people are sort of together
it's like it's a form of you know money
talks but they say and in a way it's a
way of again a form of connection of
connectivity and community and so I
think ultimately unless everyone
retreats off into and sort of gated
communities now I think we'll always
have cash in the dollar so there we are
thanks very much and hope you enjoy
reading it any questions
anybody liked anything they want to ask
try me the dollar signing where exactly
have that come from again the dollar
sign is this sort of really elusive myth
mystery touching and it's kind of in
fury because it it was first the problem
of where it came from was raised and in
Webster's dictionary late 1850s and it's
not the old thing it didn't exist say in
their 1750s
so it's somehow it appeared sometime
around the time of the war of
independence and revolution
and they're supposed to be able to track
it down and it's the wrong side in a way
they only ask the question in the
eighteen thirties they are some 1830s
but someone had come forward and said I
remember you I was the first person to
use it and in fact they opened up an old
trunk which belonged to a Florida when
Irishmen he was a trader in in Florida
before 1776 and he does begin to use all
sorts of funny squiggles and symbols
meaning Spanish dollar but it does
occasionally is this this S with a line
through it and the mystery there of
course is the use of the middle a hidden
letters so it's a bit like sort of in
Alexander Bell invented the telephone
they're wondering who to ring you wonder
how how do people how do people know
what he meant when he wrote him a letter
with this dollar sign and they didn't
even know where to put it and there was
first introduced as they put it after
the figure so I think before Jefferson
Road even with a line through it like a
sort of pound sign there's all the
confusion that wasn't really adopted and
sort of wholesale new Muse by the wasn't
used by the government tall as she Intel
eighteen twenties so it's a it isn't
really it's a recent thing there's a
total mystery so what it means somebody
doesn't mean us which is one uh sort of
that answer mister you and the ass
because this guy in Florida was using it
before that was at us I think it made us
remain a total mystery but I think it I
think it probably has something to do
with paisa and it's an is the asset pay
zone in area writing with a peek over
the top side as a heartthrob but it's
all a bit hazy is not very satisfactory
I think that's about as good as what
everything again
I don't know if you talked about this
netbook but it's always struck me that
certain of the dollar bills almost have
sort of personalities with the public
like the $2 bill is always unpopular was
considered unlucky today I wonder this
is the 20s extremely popular whereas the
10 and the 50 are quite less popular for
some obscure reason I wonder if that's
always been the case that sort of the
public becomes attached to certain
denominations but for some reason not
others yeah it's funny about the two I
carry crosses apparently was the some
point it was the was the price of a
prostitute and people didn't want to be
found with it
neither women nor the men and that was
one reason for some popularity it wasn't
far fetched reasonably nice but it
doesn't fit into the decimal system
I may have Jefferson on it maybe he
wasn't as popular as everyone thought on
the question of which there were there
were these $10 bills which are issued by
the bank of Louisiana there was called
the Citizens Bank in Louisiana and New
Orleans in the 1830s and of course they
were bilingual people to be honest on
the front it said ten on the back it had
dese they were very they were very
popular these particularly the tens
issued by this bank because they might
all have them down the river on the
steamboats because they were just about
the right amount to tender for a ticket
in Sodom and they were people to break
them for change they weren't too big but
they weren't too small they got fiddly
and sort of dirty as on so they were
very popular and people used to say they
were going to go in steamboat captain's
used to say that we're going to go down
go down and get Dixie's go down to the
land of the deep seas and then
apparently that's where the whole that's
where Dixie land comes from it comes
from the ten dollar bill and I suppose
yeah I think things really that's
inflation as well isn't it it used to be
ten announce the twenty everyone
yes
I know a little about paper money and I
was your impression of probably most
people don't recognize that what we have
is money that hasn't changed much since
1929 or 30 yeah but for the years prior
to that back to the Civil War there was
simultaneously like you have a first
greenback on gave us 5 hmm legal tender
us notes gold certificates gold coin
notes silver certificates national bank
notes of area charges with designs and
then they shrank a little in 1929 so I
save money on ink but then it just
before the crash even though there was
still silver certificates and some
national bank notes they all seem very
much streamlined and almost the same
design from then until now and I'm
puzzled most people don't know that we
have a buil during variety of the way
they looked seven or eight thousand
banks and railroads before the Civil War
and then a lot of writing and suddenly
it stops right and now it's very
conservative I think secretary Rubin
said put on all the security features
but don't change a thing which is why I
think this country missed the
opportunity that say Australia and a lot
of other places are starting to explore
it's just getting into a new sort of
design well you know celebrating first
woman in the legislature or you know an
Aboriginal inventor in Australia it's
hard to put things like that
because sometimes you hear those excuses
like I haven't heard that much about a
two-dollar note maybe they'd say there
wasn't a place in the tray for it where
was the betters note a $2 bet but for
the dollar coin 20 years ago they did
complain well they don't have space for
the tray could have been as much because
it was susan b anthony wore that it was
poorly designed or it looked like a
quarter right but they tried again with
a dollar
with a very nice coat yeah I wonder what
you thought of that the fact that it
stayed so much the same from 1929 on to
the point where in 1995 or six when they
were going to change it there was a lot
of nervousness around the world about
right what would they do it there with
their old hundred oh yeah I think I
suppose it must that must be do you
think in some way reflects on the fact
that actually American currency isn't
entirely in American currency anymore
in a way it's too powerful around the
world to suffer the sort of change so
that you know we almost parochial to put
first woman in federal government or
whatever onto it because what does that
mean to you the Russian peasant stuff
some under the mattress
all set of course as you say Oh what
does it mean if it if one day they go
around all the money they stuffed under
the mattress and they laugh your valid
because they've changed the design I
think that conservatism becomes is a
sort of funny ways of expression and
power as its people around the world
don't want it to change
they don't have a vote but I think I
think it because one of the trappings of
power people like and as a Brit I played
quite some yeah I can spot these things
because yeah the Brits stuff for these
trappings of power now that they know
the real power cept away and we've got
all those other pages and autism
the tribunes and all these most things
that go on but they are symbolically
they remain very sort of important and
emotive royalty in all that sort of jazz
and I think maybe the same goes for in
sort of America's power that is that
somehow that dollar does sort of
symbolize that that kind of fun near the
good American really stalking the world
and sorting out
welcome white spread through Europe in
addition to Italian smoothie
yeah they turn the secret of Kinetico it
I mean a person the endless it's a big
political huge political step and I
think that I was in France that you were
living in France last year when
introduced it and I asked around
no the French didn't seem to bother they
made many cuz it was a French idea it
was a French idea to rein in the Germans
and her sort of kind of site Poland and
everyone else's level because the temple
was going ahead and the Germans bought
it because they wanted to reunify the
country and they knew they look
frightening the French were frightened
they said come let's have the urine they
suddenly does push this through wasn't
really on the agenda at all until 1990
and then suddenly it became the big
thing meanwhile you know East knew it
was going up in flames but I was still
thinking about unification and the
introduction of the euro and I think
that they really missed her I think they
missed a trick in I think the design of
euros hope that song it's a promise it's
lamentable it's not that they have
archways and doorways and bridges and
they're also symbolic that we're coming
together of people's above over but none
of them are real one thing that's so
weird
but they're not you know they're not
real bridges they're in the style of
Romanesque architecture or Gothic
architecture and they each represent
epochs in European architectural
development but they're not real but you
can't say it ha that was in Germany and
that wasn't for us for that precise
reason they're they're kind of
wishy-washy colors are very good I'd hit
maybe that is the back and make it the
ideal of bridges except right they may
have started with hives I mean they
might have come up with a better name
for it I mean you're a horrible name
Elizabeth you know ready anyway in his
attach to all those things like
bureaucrat it's not it's not a sort of
year of anything you can sort of yura
fie anything by deciding the world euro
and they could have had a duck it or
something really spend it boy doors or I
mean they could have used any or aku's I
mean any other time
which names that the European money had
they could use one live but that's the
same reason they couldn't because you
know one country feel left I've his
history wasn't being represented it in
some way I think that's gonna be the
prime lady's going to be the problem
receiver the euro that that they've
achieved or attempting to achieve as a
monetary union before they've got
anything like cultural Union and in
America they achieved cup with me a long
time before their monk in fact when you
had all these women say them they had a
thousands and thousands of different
dollar bills in a country where everyone
spoke the same language but you know
we're dealing here with one currency and
come to you know in a sort of burn in
super state where everyone speaks
different languages and I know that
sooner or later the Italians are gonna
get tested because interest rates are
being fixed and please the Germans or
vice versa and those things are gonna
come they're gonna bring up much more
animosity and so difficulty than saying
you know conflict between I don't know
Ohio and California about something I
think so
so it's it's curious it's good as
interesting times I mean I think that's
gonna be very interesting to see what
English decide to do which is decide to
do you know they've been felt dragged in
the neighborhood ago
I went to Colorado Springs which
by the whole idea of the West was sort
of quite visible machine it's very
exciting to see it even with some
tarted-up and a bit sort of historical
there's some historical downtown
although I think but in a interesting to
see so that was my major trip and I
would at the San Francisco to you but
that's not the paper money become the
main source of monetary treatment in
this country well I see from the
beginning
was that wasn't enough sort of other
currency there wasn't enough bill that
wasn't enough silver around took payment
ones you know to keep business rolling
so they had to come up with something
and they were in that was in the
colonial days and they're using a peas
and shells and rum and other things he
may say alcoholics what was of a central
bank really shells was Native Americans
were in that sense oh and and so paper
money was was just a sort of very
practical answer to a to a really dire
problem of how to how to treat turning
over how to keep in business so that's
the I think that's the answer that and
really it's been like that ever since
despite to let me people I present
Jackson tried to push silver and push
back in hard hard metal Americans always
like paper money actually they've always
liked it research this
did counterfeiting come into the
equation
well if paper money came here in 1691 I
think kind of fitting came in about 1692
today people saw aha
I see an opportunity here just right off
the bat hey bird were you able to
precisely pinpoint when money became the
root of all evil
that's there was a man what's his make
cotton Cotton Mather Cotton Mather
Mather who who said yeah yeah you know
money readable actually love of money is
the root of all evil but he said he says
I'm very interesting he said that he was
thinking as I saw theologian he and as
early-american
and he said where money hasn't it been
introduced I know life is this brutish
and nasty and short and in fact he sort
of said you know and what he was saying
really is that money is a token of
civilization and I think that matters a
lot to people like him living as they
were on the edge of this wilderness and
they use money as a sort of thumb it
became a kind of token of civilization
or token of the trust that could exist
within a community so in that sense of
rather than being the root of all evil
it was the it was the sort of it was the
kind of palisade around all that was
good in their eyes and that's quite an
interesting concept I think which
particularly informed that sort of move
into paper money in the early days
so you said once the dollar originated
in America so when did it sort of start
to diffuse into the world or Europe or
are the other countries or other other
continents well um I suppose in the
First World War I think until rule that
that currency rolling paid played by the
panic I mean there's a Bank of England
that she the five-pound note which is
enormous white fatal ended and it was
good as gold you know and after that I
think that the British went into the war
with something like three billion
dollars worth of investment in the
States and they came out of it having
sold all that off and the whole that
whole relationship you entirely reversed
and America was now a creditor to the
rest of the world to about three billion
dollars and so suddenly it was it the
whole story had flipped and Churchill
got very upset about this and in the 20s
when they were trying to put put Britain
back on the gold standard and as Henry
led Britain back onto the gold standard
in order to restore the you know the
traditionals of solidity and thought
leaders here that of the Bank of England
which is caused a complete disaster
because it just left it didn't reflect
reality anymore but one of the things
was it was they wrote about at the time
is looking the dollar in the I thought
look the dollar in the eye and I said
they did and it kind of they will turn
to Spain and I think after that you know
basically the American economy is a sort
of output of dollars and particular get
these great dollar pools euro dollars
and petrol dollars and there's just some
sloshing about abroad which a which some
out there it's almost independent of the
habits of life of their own
spooky light for their own
Americans even if not especially
historians get a little confused late
19th century arguments about gold silver
I think hard money or a lose credit
might make a little more sense to us I
think a lot of this sort of read a
little about it and then decide to look
at something else instead did you get it
kind of tends to budget to sorting that
out and it dominated some elections it
really did I mean it was it's plentiful
parties I mean the populace want to
abolish money for example that's
interesting yeah exactly that's that's
very interesting I think it did the
whole silver gold question did become
the big sort of item for the 80s and 90s
you had a greenback party as well in
politics who pulled something like a
million votes in 76 and they were led by
Ignatius Donnelly who's that great sort
of visionary just rediscover Plato's
Atlantis and relocated it and wonderful
he went on to be leaders of speaker at
the populist rallies and days great sort
of sort of independent mind and I mean
from what I saw more the heat that was
generated than the light I'm not sure
whether I'm not an economist and I don't
know whether really anyone's actually
satisfactorily explained what the
benefits by the side were I think what
was interesting is that that nonetheless
that was where that where the debate was
you know that there that what was
effectively a sort of problem but about
I think it's sort of a challenge to
rural America from the suburban centers
was all couched in terms of some silver
or gold harmony or soft money I think of
that cartoon I was cutting the New
Yorker queries neither guys were plastic
with little dollar signs he's saying
some of it's hard and some of it's soft
but it's all money I don't know what the
answer to that that thing is but
certainly this
this yeah and a great wonderful
conspiracy theories as well about about
any people doing Dan gold and then the
whole Wizard of Oz for achenar which may
or may not be correct that Wizard of Oz
actually is an allegory on on that whole
populist star from the tin Mouse
industrialists and the Cowardly Lion is
William Jennings Bryan and so on it's
very convincing when you read it but
sort of almost too good to be true
really
most of the literature and the movies no
paper money how realistic do you think
that is for future yeah they do don't
they
and there's a theory that one of the
reasons that science fiction actually
one of the great Kashmir is a science
fiction is some young man is that they
don't have any money either and they
like reading whether you need to collect
to get empires where you know it really
happens without the cash I know I think
paper money is I think paper money is
bait money and we're gonna have it for a
long time because because not everything
can be done with bits of plastic yeah
and it's kind of nice to have you know
money has no character and it has no
leads no trail I mean it's sort of thumb
it's been dependent and this I think
people although it's sometimes very
convenient a little bit by the plastic
and charge it all and so on they quite
like sort of having this stuff which was
just passed is just passed around he's
no record so it may just be drug gangs
the geezers in the lock
no I haven't visited the Treasury I've
been to the Bureau of Engraving and
printing wish I went on the church I
enjoyed very much but the Treasury
Department itself no I haven't I'll take
this a big have you written any other
books beside this current book here I
wrote books about so I read a book about
some about the Ottoman Empire before and
then like before that a book about
walking across Eastern Europe which
which partly inspiration actually
becoming do something about America
because I had this injury sort of
curious feeling when I was working in
Eastern Europe in place like the back
here in Poland and those like that of a
sort of as other people missing yeah
there are people missing here where are
they they were in America so that was I
think where the idea of coming to I mean
do something about the whole America and
power came from all together you mean I
write all my life very different from
the other books you Purdue yes it is it
is visit gets birth sort of difficult
subjects like you know many soldiers
to take you a while to write this one a
year two years I'd say it took about two
years in the writing and then the
research was going on at the same time
it'll say before and though like Derrida
did come came about ten years ago I felt
you know why we've kind of interesting
to look at the dollar as a way of
looking at America and so I suppose I
was little gathering kind of material
for it and ideas for it
all that time hard isn't it because you
have to really be careful about writing
factual information and you can probably
run into someone in your book we need to
have studied this as much as you or even
more and and find some inconsistencies
yeah every that means everyone's a
terror and they'll find the sort of
horrible details could keep you wrong or
it may not be the details may be the
huge huge thing you've got wrong yeah
I'd say that my guess is what the author
is hoping to claim that he's done the
research you know this is true and I'll
stand by that
we'll say something completely
completely wrong well my words
give it your explanation at the word
dollar I'm wondering if you explore it
why sort of other currencies have taken
the name dollar like the Australian
dollar and then yeah I'm good for dollar
even though it doesn't really have any
relevance to Bearer yeah in Australia's
actually a good case in point that they
they decided they wanted decimal lies in
the 60s because until then they were
using pounds shillings and pence and
very sensible economic reasons I didn't
want to be using those anymore so they
they certainly wanted a decimal currency
able to currency reform and they were
decimalised at the same time the
government said and we've came to be
thought up new names around currency
we're gonna very cool things like come
they were called the crown and the Royal
and so forth and they will have very
similar kind of Rasul spiffing sort of
realist names okay to eat Freddie and
then that the that was a government line
and then the public sort of threw in
there they're kind of saying they all
wanted really funny nature here sort of
sort of like just redo and things they
want to take having really good names
for it as well and the opposition has
made real fun of the government being
say sort of lickspittle as to sort of
creep up to the royal family and then
the traders just said well it's
ridiculous so I just call it the dollar
and have done with it I say that's what
they did and then they said pretending
that's what they meant to do all along I
think that's why I suppose a Hong Kong
dollar is because those were silver
dollars you know the Spanish dollar was
the main staple to world trade that that
paisa up pieces of eight
there's some Thomas we're using all
international trade running to settle
accounts until the mid 19th century so
before before the American dollar became
the sort of currency of world choice it
was the Spanish silver dollar so
consciously Hong Kong and Singapore I
mean love those Far Eastern countries
were those those dollars are very highly
prized simply just maintain their link
with the dollar which is actually a
different dollar it's not in fact the
American dollar although they do use the
same symbol
now have you interested know where they
got that from you light of time training
to explore
okay I think we'll take this time have
him sign any books you may have I thank
you all for coming here it's been very
fascinating to me I never thought about
bunny has been an institution but I see
that I was wrong
let's give it up for mr. Goodwin Jason
Goodwin is the author of a time for tea
on foot to the golden horn and his
latest greenback the almighty dollar and
the invention of America it's published
by Henry halton company on the web at
Henry Holt calm